[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام في وجه لوجه هو
اذا خروج المشرف للمنتخب المغربي من
مونديال قطر بعد ان خسر اسود الاطلس
المباراه النصف النهائيه امام فرنسا هزيمه
مباراه النصف النهائي لاسود الاطلس قابلها
ربح او عوده لوعي مغربي
رغم القطيعه الدبلوماسيه بين البلدين فهل
تصلح الرياضه ما افسدته سياسه بين البلدين
وما هي الدروس التي قد نستخلصها او
تستخلصها السلطات في كل من الجزائر
والمغرب من هذه اللحظه المغاربه هل الوعي
الذي قاد من خلال هذا المونديال بان
المصير واحد والمستقبل واحد سيستمر طويلا
ام ان الخلافات بين البلدين تعد اقوى واشد
لمناقشات هذا الموضوع معنا من الرباط عبد
الرحيم المنار سليمان وهو رئيس مركز
الاطلسي للدراسات الاستراتيجيه والتحليل
الامني اهلا بك
مرحبا ومعنى كذلك من الجزائر العاصمه
الدكتور حسام حمزه وهو استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في المدرسه العليا للعلوم
السياسيه في الجزائر اهلا وسهلا بك ايضا
اهلا وسهلا سيدتي تحيه لكم لضيفك الكريم
لهم في هذا المونديال
اولا داعيني في البدايه اهني الفريق
الوطني المغربي على هذا الانجاز الكبير
الذي اسعد كل العرب وكل الافارقه حدث كبير
جدا الكل يعرف الوصول الى المربع الذهبي
اولا ساعود هنا واتحدث عن مساله اساسيه
كره القدم كانت دائما تحرك المشاعر
والمونديال بالخصوص لماذا لان في هذه
الامور تختفي او على الاقل تتقلص الصراعات
السياسيه
بانه في كل مرحله كان يصل فيها الفريق
الوطني المغربي الى مرحله معينه في
المونديال او الفريق الجزائري او الفريق
التونسي كان يحدث هناك شعور مشترك هذا
الشعور المشترك عشناه في هذه المرحله
المغاربه
و رساله ملكيه في سنه 2019 يوليوز لما هنا
الشعب الجزائري جلاله الملك على الفوز
بكاس افريقيا انا ذاك منعنا اننا في
المغرب يمكن ان نقول بان المغرب الرسمي
والجماهير ايضا هي الاعاده تكون في شعور
مشترك في الجزائر لاحظ ما بانه خرجت هناك
العديد من الجماهير شاهدنا في وهران
شاهدنا في تندوف شاهدنا في بشار ولكن
داعيني اوضح بانه يجب ان نميز كان هناك في
البدايه كيف قرانا هذه المساله في البدايه
كان هناك نوع من السكوت على مستوى الاعلام
الرسمي واحيانا لا يتحدثون عني المغرب مع
التقدم مع التقدم في النتائج وصلنا في
نهايه المطاف الى خروج جديد من الجزائريين
ولكن هنا ووضح واميز بين الجزائريين هنا
الذين خرجوا بافيا ولكن الاعلام الرسمي ضل
الى حد ما فيه كثير من الاضطراب لاحظ ما
بنوع من الغرابه في مرحله معينه وهذه كره
القدم كيف كان يتحدثون مثلا عن هزيمه
اسبانيا دون الاشاره الى المغرب في بعض
القنوات الرسميه ليس في الكل اذا تابعنا
هذا الشعور لماذا لانه هناك روابط نعرفها
جميعا تاريخيه عائليه كل هذه الامور ولكن
ميزنا في المغرب بين موقف رسمي الاعلام
الرسمي والموقف الرسمي قلت بانه سبق ان ان
الجزائر نحن رسميا في مرحله معينه ولكن
كان هناك خروج حتى شاهدنا فيديو مثلا مقطع
هو تم تداوله بكثره في المغرب لجنود
جزائريين هنا المنتخب المغربي وفرحه
بالفوز على البرتغالي
نعم نعم
الدكتور حسام حمزه حسام في رايك هل تتفق
مع الطرح او طرح منار سليمي عندما قال
هناك تشجيع للشعب الجزائري مقابل صمت
للاعلام الرسمي في رايك هل تتفق مع هذا
الطرح وان الاعلام الرسمي فغضى ذكر المغرب
في العديد من التقارير
اولا يجب ان
نهننتخب
المغرب الشقيق والشعب المغربي الشقيق ايضا
على هذا الانجاز الكره والرائع الذي في
الحقيقه شرف المغرب وشرف المغاربه وشرف كل
العرب وكل المسلمين وكل الافارقه ونتمنى
لهم ايضا مزيدا النجاحات والتفوق الكروي
في المستقبل الان عندما ناتي الى مساله
الدعم الشعبي اعتقد بانه كان واضحا واضحا
جدا بانه الجزائريين وهذا في اعتقادي ليس
عامل الكره بقدر ما هو عامل العروبه
والاسلام وتاثيرهما العابر للحدود
الجزائريون مثلهم مثل المغاربه مثل
التونسيين مثل كل العرب يشجعون الدول
العربيه والمسلمه عندما تكون في اي منافسه
وعندما يكون فريقهم خارج المنافسه
وبالتالي هنا نحن بحاجه الى ان نصحح بانه
ما يدفع حقيقه الى هذه الوحده المغاربيه
هو هذا التاثير القيمي لعامل الاسلام
وعامل العروبه وايضا عامل الانتماء الى
القاره الافريقيه لانه الجزائريين ايضا
عندما كانت السنغال وعندما كانت تونس
وعندما كانت قطر والسعوديه شجعوا هذه
الفرق وهذه المنتخبات لانها تعبر عن
انتماء واحد بالنسبه لنا
وهذا كان واضحا بالنسبه للجزائريين ايضا
مثل ما فعل وسبق ان فعل الاشقاء المغاربه
في مناسبات من سابقا
اعلامي رسمي ازاء ما حققه المنتخب المغربي
في هذا المونديال
الان بالنسبه للاعلام الرسمي اعتقد بانه
كانت فيه الكثير من القنوات والكثير منها
وسائل الاعلام التي كانت تتحدث عن
المقابلات المقابلات المنتخب المغربي
بطريقه عاديه همم الان قد يكون فيه بعض
القنوات التي ربما لم تتعرض للحدث بما
يكفي وهذا طبعا ينطبق على كل وسائل
الاعلام حتى وسائل الاعلام المغربيه لا
اعتقد بانها كلها تروجوا لي خطاب الاخوه
بين الجزائريين وهذا معروف لانه الاعلان
في الاخير ما هو الا اداه بيدي اطراف
معينه هناك من هو مستقل في قراره
والاغلبيه ليست مستقله في قرارها وبالتالي
فان ما حصل بالنسبه لبعض القنوات
الجزائريه يحصل ايضا في المغرب
ونشاهد اكثر من ذلك انه فيه بعض القنوات
المغربيه وبعض الوسائل
الاعلام التي حتى تروجوا ضد الجزائر
استاذ منار سليبي هل يمكن ان ترد على هذه
النقطه بان حتى في المغرب هناك وسائل
الاعلاميه تؤجج للفتنه بين الشعبين وبين
البلدين
لما اتحدث في كره القدم
ساعود بك الى سواء في سنه 1982 لما كان
يشارك المنتخب الجزائري اتذكر جيدا كيف
كان المغاربه يتفاعلون وكان المنتخب
المغربي هو ده الذي يلعب انذاك وكيف اصيب
بخيبه امل كبيره لما حدث تواطؤ مثلا نتذكر
جميعا في مقابله النمسا والمانيا نتذكر
هذه المساله وايضا اعود الى سنه 2019 خارج
المغاربه اظن بانه في مجال كره القدم
دائما المغاربه لم انهم كانوا يعيشون
النفس الشعور مع الجزائر ولكن ما لاحظنا
لما اقول لما اقول اتحدث هنا عن كره قدم
وليس عن السياسه لما ما لاحظناه وهو انه
في الاعلام الرسمي لوحي ده هو بالحجه حتى
مثلا المعلومات التي تقول
من الجزائر ان همم يؤكد وينفي وهي واضحه
انه تمت اقاله مدير التلفزيون العموميه
لماذا لانه تحدث عن فوز مغربي ال-
البرتغال اعتقد باننا في المغرب مميز
المعلومه
بهذا المعلومات
في سنه 2019 مثلا لما فازت الجزائر كاس
افريقيا كانت هناك اشاده وتحليل للمباراه
وكان من السماء ولكن ما لاحظناهم مثلا في
العديد من القنوات الرسميه كان هناك نوع
من البرود احيانا مثلا الى العديد من
القنوات لا يريدون الحديث عن المغرب او
يقولون بان المغرب وكانه فريق رغم انه
فريق عملاق مدرسه الان عالميه في كره
القدم يتحدثون عنه بنوع من الاحتشام ولكن
مقابل ذلك شاهدنا كما قلت على العديد من
خرجت العفويه للجماهير الجزائريه مثلا في
مدن كثيره هي همم
للدفع بالعلاقات بين البلدين قدما يعني
كيف كيف يمكن استغلال هذه اللحمه المغربيه
وتجاوز الخلافات بين البلدين
جيدا بان المغرب وفي خطابات جلاله الملك
مد يده مرات متعدده الى الجزائر وكان
الجواب وقطع العلاقات الدبلوماسيه كلنا
نعرف هذه الامور رغم ان هذه المساله التي
تحدث عنها وحده المصير الهويه المشتركه
التاريخ المخاطر التي تحيط بهذه المنطقه
وكوره القدم والمونديال وفي ثقافه قيم
جماعهنا جميعا تلاحظين بان احتفل بالمنتخب
المغربي
هذا الكلام هذا الكلام هذا الكلام يا اخي
انت استاذ العلوم السياسيه انت استاذ
للعلوم السياسيه وعيب ان تقول هذا الكلام
عيب جدا
في العلوم السياسيه تعريف التحالفات دعني
ادرس الواقعيه يعني ادرسكم الواقعيه في
العلاقات الدوليه اذا كنت في العلوم
السياسيه
مع ايران تحالفتم يا اخي جريتم وراء
اسرائيل تجون
نعود الى
اللقاءاتم
اريد ان ادرسك الدوليه
منار يواصل كلمته ثم نعود اليه
ايضا ضعيف
جدالوماسيه مع المغرب قدمت العديد من
الاسباب هذا ما كان يقصده الضيف من
الجزائر
لا اعتقد بانه الطفل يدرس في القسم الاول
نقول لهذا الوقت
لمو شخصا يعني
الواقعيه
في العلاقات الدوليه الواقعيه
من الاحترام لانك لا تتحدث انت بخير
بلغه بلغه الجامعيين بلغه هل هناك ما يمنع
من تحالف الدول مع بعضها البعض هذا شان
سيادي لنا هناك نظريه احيلك عليها
الواقعيه والواقعيه الجديده التحالفات شان
الداخليه دول لا يمكن ان تبرروا ما قمتم
به ولم تقدر ولم تقدموا دليلا واحدا على
ان المغرب اسالكم لتقطع العلاقات
اولا استاذتي الكريمه اعتقد انه منهم بين
الاشياء الجميله التي رايناها في المنتخب
المغربي انه اللاعبون المغاربه رفعوا على
فلسطين هذا دليل حقيقه على تجدر القضيه
الفلسطينيه كقضيه المحوريه بالنسبه للامه
العربيه والامه الاسلاميه في وجدان الشعب
المغربي وهذا ايضا في الوقت نفسه دليل على
انه النظام
ين نترك الاستاذ حسام
استاذ منار
اذا كان التحالف اذا كان يمثل شنق رائحه
فخطابه مقبول نعم الاتفاق الامني بين
الجزاء بين عفوا بين المغرب والكيان
الصهيوني
الموثق والموجود والمصور والذي كان في
زيارته لوزير الدفاع عن كي ينصهيوني الى
المغرب هذا في الحقيقه لا يعبر عن موقف
الشعب المغربي وهذا دليل على انه اليوم
النظام المغربي في حد ذاته لا يعبر عن
توجهات الشعب المغربي وهذا يكفي يكفي في
الحقيقه ليثبت صحه وثبات الموقف الجزائري
الذي يتماها بصوره مطلقه وكليه معه موقف
الشعب الجزائري في هذه المساله فلا نجد
ابدا قطيعه بين الموقف الرسمي والموقف
الشعبي فيما يتعلق بالموقف من فلسطين
والموقف من حكومه الكيان الصهيوني الان
عندما ناتي الى اسباب قطع العلاقه مع
المغرب
التحالف مع عدو بالنسبه للمغرب وهو عدو
بالنسبه للجزائر وهذا معرف في استراتيجيه
وفي الهويه الامنيه الجزائريه يؤدي
تلقائيا الى قطع العلاقه لانه اليوم
المغرب للاسف فضل الذهاب الى العدو بدل
التعامل اكثر مع الجزائر
الرياضه
في النسبه بين الجزائر
حتى في القضايا المصيريه لا يمكن ابدا
لنظامين يختلفين في هويتهم الامنيه بين من
يرى في الكيان الصهيوني صديق ومن يرى فيه
عدو هؤلاء لا يمكن ابدا ان يجتمع في
الاخير الشعوب تمثلها الدول تمثلها
الانظمه والعلاقات حتى وان كان هناك عوامل
او محددات قائمه عابره للحدود كما تحدثت
منذ قليل ولكن في الاخير سلطه القرار هي
بيد الانظمه وهو يد الدوله
في اتخاذ قراراتها في رسم علاقاتها مع
بعضها البعض لا تعتمد على هذه القضايا
اللحظيه والهامشيه في الحقيقه انما نتحدث
مثلا عن كره القدم بل تعتمد على القضايا
استراتيجيه والمسائل الرسميه الكبرى التي
على اساسها تتحدد توجهات الدين استاذه ما
نرسليمي ما هي المكاسب التي حققها المغرب
من خلال مشاركه المنتخب المغربي في هذا
المونديال وكيف يمكن استغلال هذه الماسب
للدفع بالعلاقات المغربيه المغاربيه نحو
الامان
الاخ من الجزائر سيقارن بين قطر الغاز
والمونديال والجزائر الجاز والبوليساريو
هل هناك هل هناك دوله تقول بان المغربي
يتحالف مع عدوه وهي تقاول تجزئه المغرب
بمعنى احتضنت البوليساريو 47 سنه ديما انا
هل لا زال من الممكن ان تخرج هذه الورقه
المرتبطه باسرائيل وانت درست اذا كنت درست
العلاقات الدوليه تعريف جيدا بانه هناك
التحالفات وهذا شان سيادي لا علاقه
الجزائر به انجازات المغرب انجازات المغرب
سيدتي
اليوم ستلاحظين بان الكل
تضامن مع المغرب وشجعنا المغرب مين طالبان
الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الى
اوروبا الى افريقيا بما لا الكل تضمنا مع
المغربي من غزه التي يقول الاخ بانهم
فلسطين وغيره حملوا الرايات المغربيه
وحملوا صور جلاله الملك الم الم تنظر الى
هذه الصور الى هذه الشعارات الكل صدامنا
مع المغرب لاحظ كل العالم اليوم نحن
صورتنا في العالم اننا ظاهره المونديال
اننا امه دوله ذا نقيم علاقات لاعبين
بامهاتهم السجود وهو السجود الله مساله
اخرى ايضا وهي القيم التي ترك الجمهور
المغربي لاحظ وقارني فقط اليوم نحن صوره
هنا في العالم واليوم ساقول لك جمله فقط
اقول هذه الاخ اليوم في نيويورك تايم هناك
عباره قالت بان المنجزات القادمه في
المغرب ستكون اكثر مما كان بمعنى انه هناك
دور السؤال الان
ويطرح على الجزائر هل لاحظتم بانكم لا
تتوفرون على ملعب واحد وانتم دوله
غازتم بانكم تركتم جمهور تائه يشجع مره
سويسرا مره يشجع يتبع يشجع البرازيل ضد
الكاميرون يحرضون وهدف الشروق يحرضونك ضد
الكاميرون باسلوب العنصري انا بما ان انا
كنت اتوقع من استاذ في العلوم السياسيه ان
يقرا هذه الظواهر يعني بحجه اسرائيل
يرد حتى نتقدم
من فضلك نعم نعم الب
وليسا تدعم قضيه تحرريه وهذا مصدر فخرا
بالنسبه لنا ان كان الاخ من المغرب يعتقد
بان هذا في الحقيقه
اتفاقا مع موريطانيا تنازل عن جزء اعترف
بانه نصف الصحراء الغربيه
ليس صحيحا
ثم اليوم ياتي على كل حال هذا ليس موضوعنا
ايضا
الانف من يتعلق وهذا ربما درس في العلاقات
الدوليه لم يحدث ابدا ان تحالف الدوله مع
عدوها هذا خاطئ استراتيجيا من الناحيه بكل
اللغات هذا خاطئ انت تتحدث
الاستاذ
لديه سؤال اخير بعيد
ارجوكم ارجوكم
يساعدون لك وبالتالي انت تحدداتك صديق له
فانت بالتالي عدو
للفلسطينيين
العلاقات
بهذا السؤال بعيدا عن هذه الخلافات
السياسيه التي لا حل لها حتى الان ما هو
مستقبل العلاقات بين البلدين في ظل هذه
اللحمه المغاربيه التي شاهدناها في
مونديال قطر
تفضل استاذ منار سليم
من الجزائر ننتظر من الجزائريين اولا ان
يؤسسوا دوله مدنيه هذا ما طالبه به الحراك
في الجزائر
انت انت لا تعرف لا قانون دستوري
على هذا السؤال بعيدا عن الخلافات
السياسيه وعن كون دوله مدنيه او دوله
عسكريه او غيرها ارجوك نريد ان نفهم منك
ما هو مستقبل العلاقات بين البلدين في ظل
هذه اللحمه التي شاهدناها في مونديال قطر
تفضل قبل ان ننتقل الى استاذ حسام لانه
الوقت ذهبنا
المستقبل هو مرتبط بعلاقه الجزائريين
بنظامهم بمعنى ان يعرفون جيدا بانه وضع
قواعد لعبه سياسيه وغارقه فيها لما خلق من
المغرب عدو وهمي والسبب هذا العدوي لكي
يحكم به الجزائريون لا يمكن للنظام الحالي
في الجزائر ان يحكم الجزائريين بدون ان
يستمر ويقول بان المغرب هو عدوله المغرب
هو دوله مؤسسات هو اقليميه ماديه له
الجزائر والان المشكله هو بين الجزائريين
وليس بين المغرب والجزائر
اولا واستدى المغرب اصغر اصلا من ان يكون
عدوا بالنسبه للجزائر المغرب الاصغر بكثير
الجزائر عدوه لك ايام الصهيوني هذا هو هذه
هي بوسطنا بوصلتنا الاستراتيجيه وهذا واضح
بالنسبه الينا من يتحالف مع هذا الكيا
المنطقيا سيد
البلدين في ظل اللحمه
عندما نعود مره اخرى الى القضايا الجوهريه
ويحدث هناك وحده في الوحده التصورات
الاسراتيجيه في الهويه الامنيه للدول
المغاربيه بين الجزائر والمغرب حينها طبعا
نتقدم كثيرا اما في ظل هذا التحالف مع
الكاينات الاجنبيه والدخيله والمعاديه فلن
يتغير
شكرا جزيلا لك من الجزائر العاصمه الدكتور
حسام حمزه استاذ العلوم السياسيه في
المدرسه العليا للعلوم السياسيه في
الجزائر العاصمه وكذلك جزيلا الشكر
لعبد الرحيم المنار السلمي رئيس المركز
الاطلسي للدراسات الاستراتيجيه وتحليل
الامني شكرا جزيلا لكما لمشاركتنا هذا
النقاش المغاربي في وجها لوجه